in times like these it is important to
connect with the people that can help us
especially with our mental health and
one of those people is without a doubt
dr. Phil McGraw and he joins us now and
Phil right off the bat
a lot of people are struggling we're
dealing with the anxiety of this thing
what would you say to them
first off Kevin you are exactly right
and in fact I am very concerned with the
mental hygiene aspects of what we're
dealing with here because I believe that
the stress people are going through
right now and the resultant anxiety and
depression and the increase in suicide
that can come from this can take as big
a toll as the virus itself in fact when
people are into this kind of chronic and
prolonged stress it takes such a
physical toll among the elderly dementia
goes up to 25% the risk of heart disease
in all people increases almost a third
when you look at the cancer population
mortality goes up 25% living with high
stress because it compromises the immune
system so much and people are not
talking about mental hygiene right now
taking care of themselves and managing
their anxiety depression loneliness all
of those things are as big a problem as
is this virus and we have to deal with
that okay what do you think is the
number one most important thing that
anyone can do well right now I think
they have to acknowledge that this is a
time-limited situation we're not in this
forever this too shall pass and I know
that seems like a hollow cliche thing to
say but you know this won't last forever
and while we're in this situation we
need to acknowledge it like for example
people are jammed together right now our
husbands and wives that don't spend time
together yeah you have four children at
home that you're having to teach now and
be home school teachers and maybe one
computer but for kids and for different
grades and you
got two dogs four kids a husband
everybody's on top of each other so
people need to have a family meeting and
sit down and say look this is a tough
situation let's not pretend it's not
let's acknowledge that we all need space
emotional space physical space and if
you're living alone and it's truly you
and the four walls move don't stay in
your pajamas all day and stay in bed you
could really get depressed get up like
you would if you were going to work get
up take a shower get dressed
open the windows get outside start a
project
I mean don't stop grooming and taking
care of yourself just because you're
shut-in you've got to continue to act as
though you were you were before this all
started start a project start a garden
rearrange your clauses do get keep
yourself busy you can't stay in bed in
your pajamas hmm I hear you how are you
dealing with this because you have a
very close-knit family and you have
grandkids who you love to have over play
with and hang out how does everybody
handle it and you work with Jay well
it's tough and thank God for technology
like you and I right now and you know
we're able to see each other and talk to
each other and we're spending time on
FaceTime with the grandkids and it's so
great to be here at night and hear that
thing buzz and go off and there they are
laughing and talking and you hear that
laughter throughout the house and stop
it and that's so great and the same with
Jay and Jordan you know Jase living in
Calabasas so we get to talk to he and
Erica that way with the kids in Georgia
water out in Malibu and we get to talk
to him there and so at least we have
this and we need to use it for that
purpose it's great technology what would
you say to families out there that are
having a problem connecting that they
don't understand the technology and what
they can do and so you have grandparents
who are suffering and by themselves well
that's the thing the older generation
are the ones that are most likely to be
the most lovely and they're the most
tech challenge so we've got to help them
we've really got to reach out to them
and say hey guys listen we're calling
you and
you've got a computer we're gonna send
you an app where we can reload on your
computer and install this for you so we
can send you zoom or send you this after
that where we can talk to you and they
will get so excited about that when they
see your face pop up it'll make all the
difference and you know Kevin I want to
say to people that are feeling empty and
depressed the fastest way to fill
yourself up is to give away what you
need the most so if you're feeling
lonely and alone to find somebody in
your neighborhood maybe it's an elderly
person down on the corner or living a
few floors below you and you've seen
them in the elevator you know they're
there but you maybe don't know them go
knock on their door and then step back
respect social this thing say listen I
know you live here alone I live a few
doors down or a few floors up and I see
you on and I just thought you know what
you might really be alone right now and
I just wanted to reach out and say hello
you probably don't want to give your
phone number to a stranger let me give
you mine and you'll call me I'd love to
listen to what's going on in your life
and here's my facebook is there an
errand I can run for you I go to the
store can I pick some things that for
you I'll leave them on your doorstep
here is there something I can go to the
pharmacy for you something I can do to
help I promise you you will feel so much
better if you will do that for people
that maybe can't do it for themselves
that is amazing advice that is great
advice and really something that we
could all do and we should all think
about doing anyway all right now what
are the challenges for you doing the
show right now because you still have an
audience that really needs you more than
ever at this time this is social
distancing
no studio audience it's very unnerving
sitting on a high chair six feet away
from people well you know you and I are
both in the CBS family and we all got
the message at the same time yes you got
it down yeah
and I hated that but I totally got it
because you've been in my studio many
times you know we've got a big audience
and three other people on staff and and
I absolutely didn't want to bring those
people in and have them on top of each
other and spreading this virus so they
said shut down and I thought you know
what our country right now is facing the
biggest mental and emotional challenge
as a country and I think they have faced
since 9/11 now that this is not the time
for dr. Phil to disappear and so that's
why I said I came home and you see I'm
here in my kitchen yeah and then I came
home and and got with my staff who are
very tech savvy and I'm able to do shows
from here in the kitchen well it's day
10 of quarantine and I'm home here in my
kitchen they don't look as good I don't
have the lights we don't have video
packages etc etc I'm talking to you
through an iPad and Robins got some of
your makeup fly to the air for lighting
and so I'm using zoom and I'm able to do
shows from here and talk to guests I
talked to somebody from Beijing China a
few days ago and New York and all over
the country and it's not as pretty and
we don't have too many bells and
whistles but still I'm able to talk to
people about things that matter well I
think at a time like this people just
want to connect with you and they want
to go to their trusted sources and
you're one of those trusted sources that
bring comfortable people so I think it's
important that they can connect with you
so tell me about the shows that you're
doing because you're doing coronavirus
themed shows well we are and we're
talking about couples in crisis we're
talking about depression and anxiety
when you shut in like this we're dealing
with those things we're talking about
about parenting during the coronavirus
we're talking about what stress and
anxiety does to your immune system
and how it makes you susceptible and
like for example when you have anxiety
it actually mimics the coronavirus
because you start having shortness of
breath right when you start having a
panic attack
you can't catch your breath to be like
oh my god that's one of the big symptoms
the coronavirus people are thinking they
have the virus when they're actually
having anxiety and so we're talking to
them about how to how to keep that from
happening and what to do what it does
happen and you know Kevin we've got a
24-hour news channels and people can
spend too much time focusing on this
they need to pick a couple of really
trusted sources like CDC for example dr.
pouchy who's from the National Institute
of Allergy and Infectious Diseases the
politicians how about you guys just shut
up let the scientists take the
microphone and talk and I'm not an
immunologist I'm not an infectious
disease specialist but I have access to
those people and I'm reporting what they
are saying I'm not spinning this by
putting any political agenda to it I'm
just telling what they're telling me the
good news is I have access to those
people where the man on the street may
not so I'm conveying what they're
telling me so very important you touched
on something though that was also
important you talked about people and
relationships and in so many
relationships are going to end after
this crisis because it's been too much
and it put a strain on people's
relationships think about it it's were
struggling think about it you've got a
relationship that wasn't perfect to
begin with
now you're jammed up in the house throw
four kids on top couple of dogs in a cat
and there's been a run on guns yes
before my guns right left what could
possibly go wrong here oh my god so
you've got to acknowledge that and just
say look we're in this we got to give
each other emotional space we got to
give each other physical space maybe you
say all right look I won't be in the
bedroom in the mornings you can be I
won't be in the kitchen in the
afternoon you can be and both of you get
outside go outside it's not raining go
outside get out free some fresh air take
the dog for a while put the cat on a
leash I don't know get out you'll do
something get out of the house yourself
some space I also want to ask you God
how much are you staying in touch with
some of your celebrity friends and
guests because there are so many
celebrities going live and doing things
right now are you staying in touch with
them and are they seeking advice on what
to do yes and yes and you know one of
the things I really hope people
understand is even though it's a serious
crisis it's okay to have fun it's okay
to laugh in fact when you do laugh when
you do have fun your body secretes
dopamine and oxytocin things that lift
your spirits up and a lot of my friends
we're exchanging funny memes and videos
and talking to each other you get on
these apps where you get a grin there
can be seven or eight of you on the
screen and one time yeah
we're we're having a ball going back and
forth we're just whoever's talking pops
up it goes we're having some fun if we
probably wouldn't had if this hadn't
caused us to stay home so we're actually
having some good laughs and some good
fun and it's okay to do that we don't
need to be so morbid all the time I hear
you on that
and one other thing for people who are
might test positive and in celebrities
especially is it important to reveal
that you have this sickness go be 19
I think so because look 85% of the
people that contract miss virus are
going to have mild to moderate symptoms
and then they're going to be sick for
four or five days and then they're going
to get up and go oh and get back to
their lives getting this virus is not a
death sentence people need to not you
know what monsters live in the dark get
the facts and understand the reason the
entire world is shut down
is not for the 85% that will have mild
to moderate symptoms it's for the 15%
that have their either elderly and/or
have underlying conditions for whom this
can be fatal and we're shutting the
whole world down for 15 percent of the
population and well we should because
you've got to take care of your fellow
man and these spring breakers that are
going on soon I don't care if I get it
right that's fine until you fill to the
store and you're standing next to Aunt
Edna who has COPD and she's 78 years old
she gets it nice because you didn't care
you can't do that we've got to care
about everybody and respect it for
everybody I agree with you a hundred
percent Phil it is always good catching
up with you and by the way I think you
said something very important people go
to your trusted sources dr. Phil is
always one of our trusted sources well
thank you so much thanks for talking to
me that you look great by the way
oh you look good look at that you got
Robins light you look fantastic at a
perfect little corner of the kitchen you
ready to rock and roll aren't you you
want to enjoy a good life Phil I'll talk
to you soon I'll talk to you soon
[Music]